- All right Ishii.
Ishii where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Compton, California.
- Compton? And tell me about your family.
You had both of your parents
when you were growing up?
- I was raised with my grandmother,
both my parents are on drugs.
- So mom and dad were
never really in your life?
- No.
- And how would you
describe your childhood?
- Loss.
- What kind of stuff went on?
- Life, depression, abuse,
disappointment, failure.
- I mean, when you say what kind of abuse?
- Molestation, physical abuse, abandonment
- And your grandmother didn't protect you?
- No, it happened to her too and
she didn't know how to handle it.
- Was it, who, was it your grandfather?
- No, two uncles, one molested me
and the other beat me.
- How far do you go to school?
- I graduated a year
early from high school.
- And where'd you go from there?
- I went to college,
I went for nursing.
And uh, after that, I got married at 19
to a truck driver that you used to
transport drugs for my family.
He grew on me, it was a
must I had to marry him.
I married him, It was
abusive relationship.
My whole side of the face got fractured.
I have a crooked back
from him, running me over
with a truck.
And uh, we got divorced
and I got married again.
It was happy, it was good.
First time in my life I
was happy and was loved
and yeah I liked him.
I was pregnant,
I had his child and a year later.
I lost my son accidentally smothered him.
I started selling drugs,
our house got raided
and they took my daughter.
I quit my job, I was home.
- How many kids do you have?
- I just have one.
I designed and printed latex
and foil balloons back in Walmart.
And uh, I worked there for 18 years.
And after my husband died I,
- So you told me how
many kids do you have?
- Just one, it would have
been three, but it's just one.
My daughter was a twin, his name was Sean.
And I didn't even know I was having twins.
He hid behind my daughter
and when I gave birth
he had come and uh, he was
here for about three months
and he passed away.
- Sorry.
- (Inaudible)
I held on, it was just after
my first love passed away
and his son too , his seed I just lost it.
I just went downhill and
I haven't come back up.
It's hard cause I'm out here alone.
No family, one child, no support system,
because I'm scared of people
having hurt you and abuse you.
It's not just that alone,
I've been alone going on five years.
Five years, no contact with
the world, no TV, nothing.
- What about your child?
What about your child?
- I just got her back.
She's nine, her name is Syrah
(inaudible)
She's wonderful, no matter
what I went through.
She's, she's a beautiful angel.
Now that I do have her back,
I'm getting a little bit back focus.
I have a wonderful man in my
life who was helping for me
and that's really having patience
and trust in God that I
will come out of this.
And I've never had that before.
Not to give up on me,
when I gave up on myself.
- Anyone in your family,
did they help you?
- I have no family.
I'm the only child on my mom's side.
I'm the sixth child on my dad's side
the youngest and the only girl.
But because I am black, my mom black
and they're Spanish, they don't accept me.
- And are drugs a part
of the picture for you?
- Yes, It's a norm.
I do methamphetamine.
It's a norm for me, but it's been so long
you don't even work anymore.
Now I just take pain pills
to go to sleep or just
to know my thoughts.
This is not where I want to be.
It's not working from,
(cries softly)
but I believe in God now and
things have gotten a little easier.
Me and my daughter is not
on the streets anymore,
she's home.
I just, I don't know I'm just lost.
I'm just lost.
I've never been so lost in my life.
I've always had a plan, a
plan B, back up, something.
- Have you, you've had jobs?
- Yes.
For 18 years I designed
balloons and printed them.
And for two years, I,
I remodeled Wal marts.
Yes. City to city, state to state.
- And you're not working currently?
- No, I currently got
laid off seven months ago.
And after I got laid off, I
really, really hit rock bottom.
I went into depression,
I had to go to a mental institution.
I had to get on meds.
I tried to commit suicide twice.
It's just an ugly
situation with depression
and drugs don't help it tends to fight us.
Intensifies it.
- A lot of these people
who are on drugs out here in Skid Row,
really just need some love
but you have to start with yourself.
And I lost that,
I lost it.
So now that I don't really care for myself
nothing even matters no more.
Sometimes not even with my daughter
because I feel like I'm
failing as a parent,
I'm failing as a woman.
It's hard, It's hard.
- It's hard to feel better about yourself
and you had to do better for yourself
when you feel so bad about yourself.
- I start believing in God.
I start believing in God
and now the drugs don't even get me high.
So that's why I went to pain pills
and now those are not even working.
- But you still need them to feel good.
- Yes, yes.
Yeah.
- What do you think may have changed your
direction in your life
when you were young?
Like if your parents weren't addicts,
perhaps, that might've been
the biggest thing right?
- The biggest thing is,
going through pain and
no one's there for you
going through something
and no one's there for you
crying out for help and no one comes,
no one comes.
And it hurts, It hurts
when you love people
and there for people and
no one's coming for you
when you cry out for help.
The most uh,
the most pain even the molestation,
is my son, knowing that
he's not here because me
he'd be three on the 16th of this month.
- This was your other child?
- This is my last son, yes.
- And what happened with him?
- I accidentally smothered him.
I went back to work too soon,
I shouldn't even went back to work
and I did a 12 hour shift.
With this particular
night, I was just so tired
I didn't even put him in his bed,
I didn't even take our clothes off.
And I'm so used to not sleeping with him.
I forgot he was in the bed.
I forgot.
I forgot he was there.
And when I saw that ahead of my husband,
the first man, the first
person that really loved me
and show me what life was about joyfully.
- So he died in the bed with you?
- I slept on him, I slept on him.
- Okay.
- He was in the bed with me yes,
I smothered him, I rode on him.
I was up under investigation
for six months.
So they came in my house,
to see how it worked with my other child.
That lasted for a little bit.
When I got raided, that's when they came
and they took my daughter,
and they took my daughter for six months.
She came home and he had
me up under investigation
for my son. So then
that's when they came in
and they started living in my house
for six months to see how,
how I react to my daughter.
Am I abusive? Do I yell? Do I scream?
You know, things like that.
And then I lost her again.
I took her to work with me,
I didn't have a babysitter.
I took her to work with me
and they called CPS on me.
I was on, I was using meth
and people at my job can tell.
So they called CPS on me
and I take my daughter to work with me.
And I was using meth
and they drug test me.
And they took her again.
This time they kept her for two years.
So I couldn't uh,
for two years just to
get my daughter back.
And uh, I went through a breakup
before she got home and it tore me up
and it got me back on drugs
and I got pregnant and
I had a miscarriage.
And it was a trigger, It was a trigger
and it got me back on drugs.
So I've been back on
meth for two months now,
for two months.
- (inaudible)
- Yeah
- But God's not ready for me
cause I don't try suicide three times
is not my time to go so
I know I have a purpose.
- Your daughter is how old?
- She's nine.
- Tonight she's with you?
- Yes.
So today well, this is
my second day being sober
No meth. I'm going to detox
because I have a wonderful person that
believes in me more
than I believe in myself
to help me go through this.
And don't judge me and
love me or my daughter.
So It gives me hope, It gives me hope
and I know that there's a God
and he's listening to my prayers.
(sobs silently)
Glen is my angel
and I know he's my angel since,
because I asked God to send someone for me
and me and my daughter was
just being funny to make sure
that we know that he was sent from God
for him to have two Coloured eyes.
- Glen's a good guy.
- And he have two different color eyes.
So I know that God sent him to help me
get better and get clean,
because that's what I asked for.
For a man to have two different color eyes
and he have two different color eyes.
So I know there's a God and there is hope.
And I believe that.
That is why I'm on my second day clean.
- Cause I know, I know there's hope
and there's a God.
Let me get through this.
He took me and my daughter out of a tent.
Well, off the streets, we
didn't have a tent then.
- You're in a mobile home now?
- We're in a mobile home now,
he took us off the bus stop to a tent
and then from a tent to a mobile home.
And now, section eight came through.
So we're going to move from a mobile home
to our own apartment.
- That's great.
- And this man don't even
know me or my daughter.
So we went from sleeping on the bus stop
to almost our own home.
Our own home.
There's hope.
I just get depressed around this time
because I know my son birthday is coming
and I haven't forgave my,
myself from my soul.
- What was your son's name?
- His name was Coloured (inaudible).
He would be three on the 16th.
- You know he just wants you to be happy?
- Yes,
I know.
- And to be with you for your daughter.
- I know and it's,
that's what keeps me going now, uh,
we have so much going
on and so many losses.
You forget what you have
and I forgot about her,
I forgot about her.
I forgot how important I was to someone.
Instead of someone being important to me,
I forgot
that no matter what this
one person would love me
no matter what, regardless
drugs or no drugs.
She loves me no matter what
and that's now that I see
It gives me, it gives me strength.
So that's why I'm on day two
of being sober, of being on meth,
being on meth for five years.
Am on day two
and I have a long way to go
but I'm not going to give up.
- Take care of your daughter
but number one you take care of yourself.
- Yes.
- Cause if you take care of yourself
your daughter's gonna be just fine.
- Yes.
- It's not easy
and I'm not saying it is but
a step, a step can take you a long way
very far and believe,
If you don't believe in God,
at least believe in yourself.
And you will start somewhere.
- Were you far the best
person on Skid Row?
- Oh.
(sobs)
I don't know.
- This is the second person
in my life that I've had
that I don't worry that
he's gonna hurt me.
He's not gonna burn me,
he's not gonna judge me
and treats my daughter
and take my daughter as she was his.
And that don't happen here in 2020.
Am Ishii Asada Shakur and that's my story.
Thank you.
- Glen is an angel.
- I know he is, I know he is.
- We're just talking about (inaudible)
- Before you pray,
never in a million years
and I didn't see it,
my dog pointed it out.
(inaudible murmurs)
- I'm not sure It's about the
eyes, but he's a great guy.